Google is taking over Moffett Air Force
Base they are leasing it from NASA
that's right for the next 60 years
there's Moffett Air Force Base right
there
it looks like it's something out of Star
Wars that looks like a transporter
leaving Hoth or something as part of the
lease Google is gonna take over the
airfield while the US government is
going to retain ownership of it and it's
a little curious what is Google doing
with an Air Force Base we've got a NASA
statement once renovations are complete
hangar one will again be home to high
tech innovation as planetary ventures
begins using the historic facility for
research development assembly and
testing in the areas of space
exploration Aviation Rover robotics and
other emerging technologies hangars 2
and 3 will be used for similar purposes
ok so that's what NASA is saying about
it I thought the story was interesting
because you know we've got Virgin
Galactic they actually had a pretty bad
mishap about two weeks ago but private
companies getting involved in the space
thing so it's a little unclear as to
what Google's gonna do here but between
Virgin and Google doing this you know
apples building that freakin what is
that thing that octagon that I think is
gonna be a spaceship and like is Google
building Elysium that's pretty much my
question like are they are they building
something there that's gonna go out into
space and then the earth is gonna go to
[ __ ]
and the Google employees and the Apple
people they're gonna live up there and
we're gonna be down here with suckers
yes yes pretty much but if so many
companies are getting into the space
race I mean is that is that a safety
issue as far as you know people doing
whatever the [ __ ] they want that private
companies doing that instead of
government yes yes yeah that's my
concern yeah what do you think are you
okay with this idea that private
companies we don't know exactly what
they're doing here which is why I'm
interested in
especially with like cuts to funding for
NASA you know them not having to do the
operations for this means they get to
actually spend more on R&D and space
exploration and stuff like that I'm
pumped about private company is getting
into the space race I mean that's like
the only way we're gonna get there and
sort of figure it all out I mean it's
like Google's building their own sort of
area 51 except we all know where it is
I'm hoping so do we need NASA anymore
because it seems to me like in during
the Cold War like we were in a space
race right Russia wanted to get there we
wanted to get there so it made us do it
and because we don't have that anymore
there's just seems to be no yeah we're
doing so we don't even fly you know we
haven't been to the moon you know where
the last time we've been to the moon
it's something like my but it's
something like 1971 it might be 1973 I
might be off but we haven't even been
back to the moon you know you may know
now they're saying well we got to get to
Mars so forget the moon nothing there
but LA so yeah I'm kind of on board this
idea that private companies can get us
there but so is NASA even what's the
point of NASA at this point if we can
sort of farm this off to Google and to
Virginia and the rest of them I don't
know this makes sense but the thought of
when airplanes were first invented and
people had were making airplanes and but
then you have the Air Force come on it
wasn't even the Air Force but the
military come in with you know better
planes and they went to war if we're
having private companies make these
spaceships I think the government has to
have the ultimate version and an even a
better version than the private sector
does I do think that NASA does need to
exist
I mean I'm curious how much were they
using that space and were they using it
at all was it just a waste of money that
makes sense that they could lease it
yeah it wasn't which there's no doubt
about that
I mean I think that like my opinion on a
lot of other industries that private
public partnerships are sort of what's
going to get us there the faster and
with the best sort of regulations or
lack thereof in some cases but this is I
mean this is a perfect test case right
it's it's something that's
extraordinarily expensive that I don't
necessarily want my tax dollars going
towards but that that I do want the
government still to have some interest
in and I know they do and more and more
I think commercial spaceflight is going
to become something that
the public is you know I think by that
by the time we're all old and sort of in
our wheelchairs our grandkids are gonna
be like oh yeah last weekend when I was
in space I didn't you know this I'm
hoping and the only way we're gonna get
there is if companies like Google or
Apple or whatever else
Virgen start to put a ton of money into
it yeah do you think that Google and
Apple at this point are basically more
powerful than the government like they
pretty much they have a [ __ ] ton of
money the government seems to be broke
like they're building things that are
gonna get us to space like it seems to
me that if Apple literally like if Tim
Cook wanted to be President of the
United States I don't think it would be
that much of a problem to make that
happen
he's not the president I don't think his
aspirations ever will be here he's a
private sector guy through and through
and then one who had spent their life
there and then gets into the public
sector is like this was a great idea
what if Steve Jobs was around don't you
think if he had said art I want to be
president now it would have just
happened like that like he could have
easily been president in two years no
it's just too many flyover States that
would be like I don't you know too many
Republicans and people on the right
they'll just be like look and maybe be
bought with massive advertising budgets
google leasing that from the government
could they just lease Kansas start some
work there that yeah all right final
thought on this do we have to get off
this mortal coil that we're on whenever
I do these space exploration things I
always say I'm a big sci-fi guy all
these movies like Avatar and Elysium all
these things where we had the you know
basically raping the earth and there's
gonna we're just gonna mess it up
between global warming and overfishing
and all that stuff do we are we gonna
have to is that the next step in
evolution of humans that we're gonna
have to go it's sort of like that'll
start Galactica we were here and we
screwed it up and we're gonna go go
somewhere else like is that it that we
have to but that we want to and that
it's you know our intense curiosity that
gets us there and not because we're
forced off our planet by imploding or
something crazy yeah because it is
within human nature to want to explore
and want to go see
that others haven't so yeah I I hope we
do actually finally get some of us off
of here yeah that was a much more
pleasant ending than mine we have to get
off here maybe but we're just gonna
choose to and that's what being human is
all about